at least five Democrats running for
presidents a Supreme Court justice Brett
Kavanaugh should be impeached over the
latest sexual misconduct allegations
from his college years a new book on
Kavanagh by two new york times
journalists mentions a previously
unreported claim President Trump and
other Republicans reject the allegations
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
why are those Democrats calling for
Cavanaugh's impeachment
well because Anthony Democrats both here
on the hill and on the campaign trail
say that these new allegations are
raising questions once again about the
integrity of his confirmation process
they say that the FBI wasn't given
enough time to adequately look into his
background at that allegations like this
are proof they came to light over the
weekend when the New York Times
published an excerpt from a new book
written by two of its reporters in it a
classmate at Yale says that he saw
Kavanagh exposed himself to a female
student at a party in the 1980s however
the female student refused to be
interviewed for the book and apparently
friends say she doesn't recall the
incident the authors also claimed they
spoke to multiple people who
corroborated a previous allegation by
Deborah Ramirez who's another Yale
classmate who says that Kavanagh exposed
himself to her at a party Kavanagh
hasn't responded to the latest report
and he has previously denied all of the
allegations but The Times reporters say
that none of the people they spoke to
were interviewed by the FBI ahead of
Cavanaugh's confirmation if you recall
Senate leaders limited the time and
scope for that FBI probe yesterday
Democratic candidates called for
Cavanaugh's impeachment senator
Elizabeth Warren said the nomination was
quote rammed through the Senate and
former Vice President Joe Biden asked
whether the FBI was pressured to ignore
evidence president Trump over the
weekend called the new accusations lies
and Tony it's important to point out
that the Senate is still run by
Republicans so the chances that
Cavanaugh is going to be impeached any
time soon are
highly unlikely all right Nancy
interesting that the alleged victim
herself says she doesn't remember it we
appreciate it